Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and a bunch of
Flash related stuff has happened since I posted
my Arrow video including the first look at
Grant Gustin’s Flash Costume.
So I’m going to be combining that with my
regular Arrow Q&A.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
the Flash TV Show has started to blow up so
much that I’m doing weekly Flash videos
in addition to Arrow every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So first let’s talk about the new Flash
Costume and then I’ll get to your questions.
Number 1 - As predicted, it’s based on the
New 52 version of the suit.
The image they released is only of the mask,
but expect the rest of the costume to look
a lot like the New 52 suit.
It won’t be exact, but really really close.
If you look closely you can see that the material
makes it look like a tech suit more than say
lycra or leather like Stephen Amell’s Arrow
costume.
I totally love the look.
I think it’s awesome that they’re sticking
with the pre-established comic book version
instead of going the Smallville route.
I don’t expect them to reveal the entire
costume until they’re ready to air the pilot.
The CW is also airing the Supernatural Tribes
pilot on April 29th.
So it’s not out of the realm of possibilities
that they could air The Flash Pilot too.
Filming starts this week and Grant Gustin
and the rest of the cast have been instagramming
the shit out of Vancouver.
Rick Cosnett who’s playing Edward Thawne
aka Professor Zoom even took a picture of
the Vancouver skyline calling it Keystone
City.
The show will take place in Central City,
if you’re not familiar though Keystone City
is the origin of the Jay Garrick and Wally
West Flash’s.
During Wally West’s run as the main Flash
Gorilla Grodd and the Rogue’s also started
attacking Keystone City instead of Central
City.
It’s also the current location of the Flash
Museum after the first one in Central City
was destroyed by the Hunter Zolomon Zoom.
No idea yet as to how it will be featured
in the new Flash TV Show, but expect a lot
of easter eggs.
Hopefully we’ll get to see Grant Gustin
in the Museum.
That would definitely strengthen the rumor
that John Wesley Shipp is playing Jay Garrick.
I’ll report more from the set next week.
Let me know what your reactions are to Grant
Gustin’s Flash costume.
Now let’s get to your questions!
Number 1 - Magus 3691 asks What will happen
to Laurel now that she is cleaning herself
up? and When will they have Roy more involved
with the Arrow Team?﻿
She’s probably going to start pursuing Brother
Blood again.
I think the show is going to give her the
satisfaction of taking him down.
And Roy will be a big part of next week’s
episode The Promise.
I’ll talk more about him in a predictions
video.
Question 2 - Ali Camel asks When do you think
the flash TV show will start airing?
The expectation is that it will air back to
back with Arrow so it can benefit from the
built-in audience.
Since Arrow is already really early they would
probably air it after.
Typically when they do things like that the
bigger show goes first to draw in more eyeballs,
hoping that they’ll stick around for whatever’s
next.
That’s why they put the brand new show this
year, The Tomorrow People right after Arrow.
Question 3 - Scott Smart asks If this doesn't
get an A from you, what kind of episode will?
I really like to reserve the best grade or
rating or whatever for the very few things
that I think are the best of all the things
I watch.
So I don’t just compare episode of Arrow
to other episodes of Arrow.
I’m comparing it to Walking Dead and Game
of Thrones and Doctor Who.
Ideally there would only be a few A’s per
season.
Just because it’s not an A doesn’t mean
it wasn’t awesome though.
Question 4 - vegtabadass asks Question do
you think Slade will turn Roy to his side
or at least try?
Yes, I think you or someone else made the
Anakin Skywalker - Emperor comment.
He’ll definitely try, but the funny thing
about Arrow is that like most comic book stories,
it’s not super hard to predict the outcome.
He’ll almost turn Roy and then in the hour
of need he’ll rally back to the good side.
In this case though, no.
I think Roy will go a little nuts, but he
won’t start working with Slade.
Question 5 - Joe Kerr asks Are blue beetle,
metal men or booster gold are going to make
appearance?
So yeah, there have been all the Kord Industries
easter eggs.
They have stuff in development, but in terms
of who would come on first?
I would say Ted Kord.
And it would play out like the Grant Gustin
episodes.
He’d reveal himself as Blue Beetle to Oliver
over the course of a two part episode.
Booster Gold is also really high on the list
of people I think Geoff Johns would like to
see on the show.
They usually reserve big news like that for
Comic Con though.
So expect to find out which big new characters
are coming in a couple months.
Question 6 - Laxus Dreyar asks Do you think
Laurel finally deciding to in no uncertain
terms "grow up" was because of what Oliver
said to her about having loved her half his
life but that he was finally done?﻿
I think she was already on the fence and he
just helped push her over.
I think it was mostly Sara and her family
that were helping her.
But he did kind of verbally slap some sense
into her.
Question 7 - Rick Grimes asks Do you think
team arrow will try to fight Slade next episode
but then get beaten badly?
You’re not looking so good Rick, you should
really put a band aid on that.
I think that Oliver’s face is going to look
like your face after next week.
Roy is also supposed to get his ass kicked
too.
Question 8 - Smoak and Arrow says I think
Slade hacked the phone to lure Oliver there
so he was totally caught off guard by Slade's
presence.
Yeah, that was weird, I think it was either
Slade manipulating Oliver or Thea had been
kidnapped and was trying to get help.
We’ll find out next week.
Question 9 - Mobbmaster asks Will Felicity
train a bit or something sort of like that?
Yes, the writers said that Felicity would
continue to train with Diggle, there won’t
be any big training montage scenes like last
week, but it’s implied that she’s still
learning how to physically defend herself.
She’ll always be wonderfully clumsy though.
Question 10 - leigh slaydragons asks do you
think that Slades, "I will corrupt those he
loves" refers to Sara with the huntress or
Moira?
Yes, I definitely think he’ll try to corrupt
or kill Sara.
In his speech he said “Kill Those Who Follow
Him.”
I think when he talked about those he loves
he was just talking about his family, so Thea
and Moira.
Moira is one of the most corrupt people on
the show already.
Bonus question - thedeentheory asks will there
ever be a time when the "island story" is
finished and the present day stories keep
going?﻿
Remember when they told the island story from
Sara’s perspective.
I think they’ll do a little more of that.
But he was on the island for 5 years.
Which is a lot of time.
So I think they’ll get creative and add
new dimensions to the island.
I’m also hoping someday they’ll tell Flashback
stories for Sara’s training with the League
of Assassins.
Thanks so much for submitting your questions
again.
I’m sure while I was making this you all
thought up a billion more about Grant Gustin’s
Flash Costume.
Feel free to write all those in the comments
and I’ll try to answer them there.
Remember, next week is huge.
The Promise is supposed to make the Season
1 finale look like a bad student film.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video.
I’ll probably even do a predictions video
in the next couple of days.
Right now click here for my episode Review
and click here for my latest Flash Spinoff
video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!